[Musique]
m
il ya deux choses que je déteste par
dessus tout la première chose c'est être
mal assis et là en l'occurrence c'est le
cas et la deuxième chose c'est monter
des meubles
ça tombe bien aujourd'hui je vais
solutionner le premier problème c'est à
dire être mal assis par contre se
confronter au deuxième problème à savoir
monter un meuble
je déteste mon téléphone quand il s'agit
d'aller faire les courses à la maison
est d'acheter un meuble et de le monter
c'est pas moi qui m'y colle c'est ma
femme ça c'est ma femme qui la montée ça
c'est ma femme qui la montée ça c'est ma
femme qui l'a peint je déteste monter
les nomme seulement aujourd'hui j'ai la
chance d'avoir reçu un très bel objet
qui est juste là ça très très gros très
très beau c'est une chaise qui m'a été
envoyé par un vrai qu une chaise de
bureau vous a déjà parlé dray qui a pas
leurs pendants montech mon pote
guillaume une chaise de gaming bon ça
c'est le début on est pas mal est là
aujourd'hui mais on va monter vous
n'êtes pas réellement une chaise de
gaming ça pourrait être ça fait
vingt-cinq kilos de bazar c'est le
carton est juste lourdes on n'arrive
même pas le bouger ses chaises de bureau
hyper confortable qu'on peut utiliser
pour gainey qui équipe aussi être
utilisé pour le bureau c'est la r go max
2 rect
j'espère que c'est pas trop compliqué à
monter je déteste monde et les meubles
c'est juste hyper massif ce truc
est énorme
je crois que ça doit être le pied
[Musique]
petit message pour guillaume avec qui on
avait monté la chaise drake et l'autre
dernière fois j'ai l'impression
guillaume que c'est beaucoup moins dur
avec cette chaise donc je suis bien
contente cette loi qui ont des chiffres
fois ça c'est quoi c'est un espèce de
métal
ce truc ça pèse 15 mille tonnes ça s'est
séparé c'est un espèce de d'alliage de
métal la dernière fois on a tourné la
vidéo avec avec guillaume on était chez
lui il a mis une heure pour monter là ça
m'a pris deux secondes je prends je sens
les pieds je mets les roulettes je mets
le le pompe à gaz je sais pas comment on
appelle ça je poserai dessus pas terminé
ça c'est cool je les ai bien que sorti
trop simple si il reste ça y est ça la
phase aller c'est l'appui tête et je
pense que là j'aurais fait le tour
rect c'était quasiment un sans faute là
je vois que j'ai quand même deux vis à
monter je déteste monter les meubles ont
pour devise je pense que je devrais y
arriver le montage au final qui pour moi
toujours une galère pour les meubles
après coup c'est l'installation je
trouve si tous les fabricants de meubles
le faisais ça ça serait génial très très
longtemps à monter des meubles
rect on en selle c'est très simple c'est
vraiment ça qui est intéressant avec
cette chaîne c'est que vous connaissez
probablement pour les chaises de gaming
il en est sûr rect office la partie
bureau bureautique en avions toujours en
je dirais les codes du gaming hyper
light le confort toujours est quelque
chose de vrai bon coup qu'on peut régler
tous les côtés alors je vous montre
comment marche cette seule sa vaste
ouais je vous explique c'est hyper coupe
du haut vers le bas
vous avez plein de choses de réglable
plein de possibilités on commence déjà
par c'est de partir c'est la partie pour
venir poser votre tête vous en doutez
vous pouvez la règle et comme vous
voulez vous larguiez à 45° donc hop
comme vous voulez tak tak cela mais
comme ça je la mets comme ça je la mets
comme ça là mais quand même ça je
l'avais comme ça en gros je peux
vraiment de calais la tête comme je veux
pour éviter effectivement les fatigues
cervicales lorsque vous bossez sur un
ordinateur donc ça c'est cool déjà
envoyé regarder l'inclinaison est juste
folle comme ça comme ça c'est vraiment
cool comme ça en fonction de la
morphologie quelqu'un vous allez pouvoir
la cale et comme vous voulez autre point
et pas des moindres le dossier vous avez
dit fait rentrer en europe font remonter
tout en haut et on se fixe à leurs
descendants nous choisissent et la
hauteur que vous voulez en fonction de
votre morphologie
puisqu'on est derrière regardez la halle
là j'avais 4 1 qui sont complètement
réglable de la même manière en hauteur
pour vous puissiez qu'elle est
volontaire comme vous souhaitiez parce
qu'on n'est pas tout c'est pareil qu'on
n'a pas tous besoin des mêmes appuis
puisqu'on en est là on a aussi une
partie qui bouge
la partie sur laquelle je suis assis ça
ça peut bouger vous avez un petit bouton
qui se trouve sur le côté le bouton se
trouve juste là pour appuyer et vous
allez avancer ou reculer la partie ici
voiliers de votre siège pour revenir
près non réglés comme vous voulez en
fonction de la taille de vos jambes
bien sûr ça ne s'arrête pas là vous avez
aussi les accoudoirs qui sont
complètement réglable les accoudoirs
sont réglables et vous allez voir que
les accoudoirs vous allez pouvoir régler
pas mal de choses avec un système de
palettes comme dans une formule
accoudoirs 2d vous pouvez les tournées
comme vous voulez fonction de la
position que vous souhaitez vous et les
régler en hauteur voulait monter cran
par cran et va vous est arrivé tout en
haut ça redescend vous les mettez comme
vous voulez
ensuite vous avez un système de palettes
la cette palette va régler la hauteur du
siège tandis que de l'autre côté vous
allez qu'elle et l'inclinaison du
dossier vous pressez apparaître une fois
ça libère le
vous allez pouvoir venir vous à
montrouge et comme vous voulez par
contre vous relever voyez ces cartes pas
la position donc là vous faites vraiment
comme vous voulez si vous voulez que ça
bloque
il faut venir presser la petite palette
l' oblige m'allonge je presse la palette
et hop là c'est bien la position je
reposte la palette il revient pas j'ai
pas le prendre dans le dos il faut que
j'ai de moi avec mon dos l'enclencher
pour libérer et ensuite je reviens
position là je vais pouvoir régler la
dureté à savoir que lorsque vous allez
venir vous inclinez ça va être plus dur
- dur comme vous le souhaitez sony
annonce de 40 à 120 125 kg si je dis pas
de bêtises en fonction de la corpulence
de la personne qui va venir s'appuyer
dessus
vous allez voir une résistance qui va
être complètement adapté mais surtout ce
qui est coup avec cette chaise c'est la
sensation de robustesse parce que là
vous avez un aluminium la chaise elle
pèse une tonne
on est à 25 kg le carton dont bien
évidemment le carton ça pèse pas grand
chose donc une fois que vous avez votre
chaise elle pèse une vingtaine de kilos
je dirais c'est juste monstrueux
vous avez ici c'est dur c'est du plain
pareil en bas c'est dur c'est du plein
vous avez un verre inquiète la qui coule
qui est solide enfin moi je la trouve
bien et ce qui est ou et chez vraiment à
st elle sait que pour coup je vais avoir
une vraie chaise de confort pour bosser
ça c'est bien ça va éviter sur les
grandes sessions montage de venir se
faire mal au dos doit être pas bien de
travers si et ça là je peux me caler
comme je veux si je veux un peu plus
vous mettre un mot dans laxe je peux le
faire
en plus de ça le revêtement est assez
doué assez confort avec des petites
finitions cuir sur le côté sur le devant
c'est pas mal je trouve que d'un point
de vue global en termes de fabrication
c'est bien vous avez la marque qui est
noté la la marque qui est noté la le
gorec tu que vous retrouver ici dans le
dos c'est une chose qui est très typé
qui est très racée il faut aimer mois
sur sa pas mal il ya plusieurs couleurs
moi je les prie tout noir histoire que
ce soit beaucoup plus doux beaucoup plus
light que ça passe mieux dans votre côté
bureau mais ce qui est chouette c'est
que des gens dans une sensation de
robustesse en termes de confort on est
vachement bien on peut le cas les come
on veut on peut complètement la
personnaliser je sens assez intéressant
je sais pas vous dites moi ce que vous
en pensez est ce que vous êtes gamer est
ce que
vous avez une chaise direct ou es ce que
vous avez une chaise gaming à la
concurrence ou pourquoi pas qu'est ce
que vous pensez des chefs gaming et
est-ce qu'une chaise comme ça qui est
entre le gaming et le bureau pourrait
vous intéresser
mais en tout cas ça vient je trouve ça
bien pour les personnes qui passent
beaucoup beaucoup de beaucoup de temps
derrière un bureau qui aiment ce look
qui est très typé et surtout qu'ils
cherchent pas à chaumont confort alors
une chaise comme ça c'est pas cadeau
cadeaux c'est un produit qui coûte 599
euros c'est un budget par contre c'est
intéressant si vous passez beaucoup de
temps à bosser
c'est un plus pour l'équipe
professionnelle si vous passez beaucoup
de temps derrière un ordinateur qui vous
faut du confort 600 euros c'est un
budget mais ça se réfléchit également
par rapport à votre dos par rapport à
votre santé le modèle que vous est
présenté c'est là ergo max il ya aussi
la r go qui coûte 499 euros en tout cas
moi je trouve vraiment intéressant je
trouve plutôt cool et l'a envoyé à
pouvoir bosser dans des conditions je
vais te proposait lui pour en faire
encore plus ça c'est plutôt cool dites
moi ce que vous en pensez en bas en
commentaire vous invite à vous abonner
pour suivre toute l'actualité de la
technologie en général il ya plein de
choses qui vont arriver plein de
surprises plein d'actu plein de tests
grandes choses donc à voyez vous je vous
embrasse donne rendez vous dès demain
prenez soin de vous tiens